[Music]
hello everyone
and welcome today's webcast about api
governance 2.0
a key element for security and scaling
api programs
my name is raymond peng and i'm a
digital engagement lead at google
and i'm also joined with ruben gonzalez
hi everyone
i'm a customer engineer for apigee
awesome
all right so before we get started just
a quick
few housekeeping items you're going to
see on the console
in this webcast on the left a place
where you can put in
your cue in questions and answers you
can post your questions at any time
during the webcast
but please note that you don't have to
wait until the end of the session
uh you can ask it at any time we'll try
to answer them either at the end or
offline after the webcast
also you'll see a resource list on the
right uh we will post some links
and other things within the resource
that we mentioned during the webcast
so you can access them as well that way
so let's take a quick look at the agenda
for today's webcast
the first thing we're going to talk
about is a paradigm shift in api
governance so what is this api
governance 2.0
all about anyways we're also going to
start with creating
consistent and security api patterns for
apis
and how you can use them to ensure
adherence and compliance and standards
for your apis
and then we'll show you how apogee can
help you do that so the software that
applies
this api governance 2.0 concepts as well
as the technology
and hopefully they'll help our audience
understand how they can build
and test apis much much faster than
they're doing today
so with that being said let's take a
look at kind of where
companies are at you know a lot of
companies have invested in apis they
might have hundreds or even thousands of
apis
and those who have them are primarily
started with
uh this integration method basically
apis that we're
calling system to system but you know
with digital disruption ribbon
you know so many things have happened in
terms of emergence of cloud
you know the changing power of the
consumer and the emergence of
new competitive threats for a lot of
different companies in terms of
other crossovers that are trying to eat
their business away so
you know now companies are starting to
use the apis in a much more expansive
way they are
integrating with partners so they're
going external they're putting them on
the cloud
and they're using them to monetize and
actually find new sources of revenue so
really transformative
but in the end so now you've got maybe
you had 10
or 100 or a thousand apis but now they
were all internal but now they're also
external right and so that creates you
know this concern that you have all
these apis
you know in your organization internal
external but at the same time
you still got to go fast and there's
that concern about
uh security so there's sort of this
balance right in terms of
well i got to go fast i need to be
competitive but how can i get this speed
that's right so um and this is and we
we usually see this happening too often
right so now organizations are
thinking of security as an afterthought
rather than something that
need to be prioritized even before
thinking of what
which capabilities they're going to
start exposing through apis right
they're getting all this pressure from
the from their competition they need to
deliver
uh as fast as possible however um well
you see
um there all these security issues are
being uh
are not being addressed correctly and
then surprised now
they're being attacked or now the uh the
some malicious user found a
vulnerability and now they're they're
using all their data for
malicious purposes so um so yeah this is
happening too often so how
how did it how did we come to this place
right how did we
did it come to happen and well it's it's
pretty simple right so organizations
they want to they want they want to
innovate really fast right however it's
not as simple as just exposing some
digital assets to an api
yeah of course they need to deliver all
these new experiences as fast as
possible however they're still dealing
with the same legacy and all systems
right
and some some development teams they're
just exposing services just because they
can
right they're just building a rest uh
interface on top of their legacy systems
and they're forgetting about setting the
right security patterns perhaps they're
not thinking on how they should be
scaling uh their apis the right way they
are losing visibility on who are the
real users of those three
apis so that whenever they bring a new a
new revision or a new update to their
services
they lose control of the updates that
they're making to those systems right
in a sense uh they're uh creating these
api
sprawl environment right so they are
losing control what's going on within
the api program
yeah yeah it's a real problem and um you
know it's it's kind of like the more you
create
apis it is a benefit but it creates lots
of different security holes and
especially if you're doing them all
differently
and so you know a lot of companies are
looking at you know the typical it
method which is big
g governance so i'm going to put rules
gates and enforcements you know i'm
going to make sure that i'm controlling
every little thing
and that there's approvals for releases
and lots of manual reviews
you know that accompanies with big
documents and also a lot of different
time spent on online
and corporate politics so you know
there's kind of a problem reuben right
so it's like you know we've got all
these security concerns we've got to go
fast
but because of that security now we have
this big cop in the middle
right and that's pretty that that can be
really detrimental and so if you look at
you know from a standpoint let's say
we've got an api team they
they've already ready to release their
apis or build their apis
they start out happy but they get to
this first standpoint which is they have
an architecture review so now that's a
speed bump
then they have to go to api design
reviews someone has to make sure that
they're using the right approach and
they're
using reusable and making sure they have
the right policies in there
or they have an internal standards
review and then finally when they go to
deploy
there's a whole bunch of checklists that
they never were aware of and so what
happens in these four speed bumps
there's
tons of rework within the cycle and so
if you're a smart team
you know you're gonna prepare in advance
and you're gonna get all your documents
ready
but you're gonna this this process is
probably such a headache that you start
to bundle all of
your apis together so rather than
getting one approved i'm gonna put 20 or
30
and so pretty soon we're back to
waterfall the other thing is
i know some of the loopholes i know i
have relationships i know people
and i know what they're kind of looking
for and they know me so i might just
sidestep this process and in the end
what happens there we
basically the something that we designed
to keep us secure
is now people have found a loophole and
found the path of least resistance
so this is a real bad problem right so
it's like there's no good way to solve
this right reuben i mean i think that's
the challenge where we are today
i mean there are different ways of how
we can address this we
we can see this as a process driven
solution or perhaps uh making a mix
including as part of the makes
the right tool for you to be able to
address these issues yeah
and so before we get into tools i think
as technologists you know we always
think about how can we use tools
i think the most important thing that we
find with our customers and
organizations it's a really
a mindset shift first and so at apogee
we call api governance 2.0 and we wrote
this manifesto
working with hundreds of customers
worldwide and we've seen their programs
go
grow based on this kind of mindset and
so the first one is really around
empowering and enabling over enforcement
right how can i help my api teams
give them the tools give them knowledge
give them the ability to make
decisions right then the second is
guidance
and support over policing the third is
accelerating progress over slowing
change so really it's
it's a dynamic right i'm not focused on
how can i overturn everything and look
at it i really want to focus
on speed how what can i do to keep these
teams
going fast and last is this
relinquishing of a centralized control
so
trust and federation over centralized
control and i think trust is not
something that you can just basically
say
trust me you have to build trust into
your system
so that's the cornerstone i think of the
mindset change this manifesto
of governance 2.0 and so that really
means you know a lot of teams
they call them api centers of excellence
but what we want people
to shift to is this api center of
enablement
and so what does that look like you know
i think really quickly
big g governance versus little g culture
that's really the shift in terms of
big g governance to this government 2.0
that means
i'm going from rules to gates and
enforcements to principles standards and
empowerment
you know i used to have top-down design
and planning and big waterfall
now i have separation of concerns i have
an enterprise concern i allow teams to
do what they need to do
i'm going from approvals for releases to
criteria based and continuously reasons
i want to make people to understand what
it means
to pass go and to hit the criteria so
that they can always release
constantly at their speed and i'm not
going to do manual and analog processes
i'm going to look at how i can create
self-service
through automation and tooling and i'm
going to enforce
um i'm going to enforce community
knowledge
and community documentation rather than
centralized word documents
and then the last couple two you know
i'm going to have cross-functional teams
and coaches
i'm not going to have distinct big
handovers from teams which is very core
to the way of agile thinking
you know same thing as governance 2.0
and that instead of spending all this
time aligning
and building corporate politics i'm
going to focus on building tools
ci cd uh to help the teams go faster so
that they're essentially using
efficiency based
tools rather than alignment and time
spent and wasted
meetings and politics if i have that i
have this api governance 2.0 ribbon
let's take a look at the process that we
have today there's four points
api architecture design right standards
and then deployment and in live so how
can we use
technology in this case how can we apply
the principles of api 2.0
uh to all four of these things yeah can
we can we let's let's do that and try to
solve this problem together
definitely so from an architecture
standpoint perhaps you
might want to look into a way to
standardize
globally and across all your existing
architecture doesn't matter if they're
deployed if you are deploying a cloud or
multiple cloud providers or even
on-premises
you want uh to build a layer of
abstraction of the on top of your
existing services so that you can
enforce and not only enforce but
decouple common security patterns from
your existing system
supporting your existing uh apis right
so that you're going to be able to build
this layer of abstraction and
and and essentially this will become a
shield that is going to
is going to protect both the
interactions from your existing api
consumers and also
into the secure interactions between
this platform and your backend systems
by setting up this layer of abstraction
you're going to be able to standardize
all your security patterns and make sure
that they're enforced correctly perfect
so if i'm an api developer
i do i deploy an api to the api platform
it's automatically i'm automatically
going to gain the benefits of
threat protection the security and the
patterns that you're talking about
so i i'm essentially kind of deploying
on a trusted
uh trusted platform that is correct so
essentially you're building secure
interactions between your api consumers
and your backend systems through a
standardized shield or layer of
abstraction in a plat
api platform what are some of the
examples of the patterns that you're
talking about
uh so perhaps from a network perspective
you're going to be building uh
trust relationships within the platform
and your back and systems perhaps you're
already using an existing security
pattern
so the only thing you need to do is to
set up a really simple
trust relationship between the api
platform and your existing backend
systems perhaps you
you can build up a very simple neutral
tls setup
perhaps if you're looking into a token
based authentication mechanisms that's
something you can build
upon however if you want to reuse what
you already what you already have you
can
you can do it and then you can keep
progressing
those patterns so that you can start uh
standardizing once new projects come in
right and the same story goes on the on
the consumer
uh relationship right uh perhaps your
organization might be thinking on
setting up
odd as a standard across the board
that's something that you can enforce at
this layer
perfect perfect so i've got my api
management set up now
i've got the security architecture in
place you talked a little bit about
oauth and security
can you tell me a little bit more about
now let's dive in i've got a couple of
apis
definitely so usually uh from a
development standpoint this is this
happens too often right
each and every time you have to expose a
new service uh
we developers need to sometimes get too
creative and start setting up new
security patterns so new ways to secure
our project or apis right
and for each and every project we have
to set up that pattern however
there's a best way to do it so once you
build this layer of subtraction perhaps
you
you can also start decoupling this
pattern so that no longer the
is a developer is going to be the
developer task to have to come up with a
new security pattern
then essentially after decoupling these
patterns you are essentially
essentially creating shareable libraries
right and in this case
in in this case you can decouple an
authentication and authorization as your
library through a policy right but now
the developer doesn't
don't doesn't have to come up with all
this and then he can really focus on the
business value that he's going to be
exposing through an api
yeah we love creativity but not when it
comes to security right
that is correct we want to build best
practice and standardize
exactly so and remember uh security is
not all about
just authentication and authorization
perhaps you want to protect your apis
against
ddos attacks or perhaps against
content-based attacks that's something
that again
it's great that you're thinking of the
on those uh different issues however you
just need to have to come up with those
uh
patterns once and and perhaps you're uh
the the person in charge of design or
designing or identifying those patterns
is a completely different
stakeholder than from a developer from a
developer standpoint right
perhaps in your own organization you
already have a security team
that is in charge of the making sure
these patterns are applied
are applied correctly throughout all the
apis that you're going to be exposing
so you you will need to have the right
tool that it will enable you to have
this separation of duties right
the developer team the api team will
focus on the real business value through
that are going to be exposing trade
through apis and of course the security
stakeholders are going to treat
these shared security policies as a
non-functional requirement right
although they are very important you
just need to come up come up with them
once and then you don't have to worry
about them you can keep redeploying new
apis and you don't
you don't need to do all the
revalidation process for these specific
aspects of your releases
right so it's almost like the path of
least resistance if i'm a developer
and i'm creating apis i mean i'm you're
actually making my life a little easier
right i just got to focus on the request
and response of the payload
and the business logic there but all the
stuff around the shared security
policies is no longer
a thing that i have to be concerned with
if i deploy on the api
platform i'm automatically getting some
of these policies for
for free they're added all right right
that is correct and
still you you might want to have the
right tool just because you will still
want to have certain level of
flexibility
perhaps you uh you're going to come and
come up with specific uh
parameters that are going to be able to
let the api team to decide which uh
rate quotas the rate or quota you're
going to be applying per api or api
product so again
you still want to have that separation
of concerns in regards to policy
enforcement however there are certain
levels of
parameter parameterizing options you
might want to leave
to be the responsibility of the api team
or even a business team
nice nice so i get that flexibility and
also you know anybody who uses the
platform says hey security's already
been involved
they've actually been part of the
architecture of the policies even that
are being added which is really great
remember we're talking about uh
artifacts here so
every software uh product nowadays have
to go through a software development
life cycle
and the best way to do uh all these
releases is through an agile process
right so in thinking in terms of an api
platform and uh everything that you're
going to be deploying within this tool
we're thinking in
configuration terms so usually we have
to train these configuration artifacts
as if as if they were
any other supper artifact right so
they're going to have a
a release process they're going to have
a
they're going to have specific stages
where you might want to run some quality
uh
quality checks and and you're going to
you're going to want to make sure that
you're applying and
and and and making sure that the right
security uh
policies are being enforced even before
deploying this configuration into the
platform
right after the after the these
configuration artifacts are deployed
into the
platform you want to make sure that even
though they already
they were already pre-validated once you
deploy them then you
you can rerun some tests uh to be able
to uh
to uh to have a full integration test
results
from your from the consumer side all the
way to your backend system so again
you will have even multiple security
this kind of life cycles will enable you
to have multiple security chase
checks before deploying and even after
deploying nice
so there's a lot of tools in the ci cd
pipeline that you're talking about right
yeah definitely and the beauty of it is
that
every customer is different and as well
every customers might be in
a different station in in regards of the
maturity level
on on using some agile server
development life cycles and pipelines
so uh so most organizations want to be
able to reuse what they already got
right
you don't want to get a platform that is
going to force you to choose a specific
set of tools right you want to have
flexibility so and that's great from a
developer
standpoint right you don't need to
rethink the wheel if you already used to
handle java source code most likely
you're going to be relating very often
to maven
right so you might want to you might
want to uh
to have an option for you to be able to
deploy configuration artifacts through
maven
so that's something that apigee provides
for our customers
so uh another thing if you're uh perhaps
a web developer
you might be more comfortable using
javascript based tools so
also apigee offers some plugins for you
to be able to deploy configuration
artifacts into the into the platform
using javascript plugins
and again the sky is the limit uh if
you're
if you're already using a ci cd
orchestrator orchestrators or such as
jenkins that's something that you can
reuse and build up a pipeline for all
these artifacts that you're going to be
pushing into the platform thinking about
source control each and every major
organization that handles uh
software development of course they
might have chosen a specific version of
or a specific product for um for source
control so that's something that is
really standard in the industry and
actually we promote it as a best
practice also for our configuration
artifacts
so apigee is really flexible right we
can we can adapt to all these tools
i think the back to the security point
is we see a lot of companies
who are using and adding like linting
tools they're adding their uh security
testing tools
they're adding custom like regular
expressions and other types of quality
checks
right into the ci cd pipeline right so
when they're deploying their apis to the
cicd process
it's actually going through additional
checks both security
compliance and any other kind of you
know standards that they're trying to
cover
right that's sort of the power of the ci
cd is that they're mastering and they're
automating it
through this deployment process that is
correct yeah
so what happens about uh you know now
i'm live like what can we do about
monitoring so once
once your apis are exposed to the public
of course you might want to still
be able to monitor to monitor what's
going on within your api program right
you want to be able to address specific
uh threats uh or or even malicious users
that might be
uh well trying to break your existing
systems or
trying to steal your information right
so with you want to have a platform that
is going to be able to
that that is we will allow you to define
monitoring alerts
right and then for you to be able to
investigate what's going on into the
platform in real time
and act upon it right so something that
is pivotal to for
for any kind of us any kind of platform
and of course it's very important for an
uh for a platform that is gonna be
sitting
right in the middle within your api
consumers and your backend systems
yeah sounds like a really good tool to
have especially when i
have thousands of apis or hundreds and i
really don't know kind of like how
they're
how much protection i've have and if
people have been deploying in the class
and i haven't been able to manage them
this is a great way to monitor so let's
take a look at um
you know let's take a look at some of
these things in action so ruben's gonna
open up apogee we're going to take a
look at when we talk about enterprise
policies and how we're securing them
and reusing them ruben's going to show
that we're going to show you the
developer experience which is
you know from a developer standpoint
how's that look like and then we just
talked about monitoring security so
let's take a look at those dashboards
that are coming out of the box
uh from apigee so uh let's let's get
this going and
let's take a look at uh the demo the
first time you're gonna be logging into
the platform this is the screen that
you're gonna see
okay uh the ph platform is within the
iph platform
essentially you're going to be deploying
configuration artifacts right uh today
we're going to be showing
uh two different configuration artifacts
we're going to be showing api proxies
and also shareflows okay so let's get
going
so i'm going to click over here in api
proxies over here each and every
of these entries that you see on the
screen it represents an api proxy
an api proxy essentially is a
configuration artifact that
will allow you to augment the
capabilities of the endpoints that
you're exposing through the platform
some kind of uh some examples of this
augmentation capabilities perhaps you're
thinking of the forces security patterns
perhaps on lightweight mediation perhaps
on traffic management
those are the kind of patterns that
you're going to be decoupling from your
backend systems and you want to enforce
them within the platform
okay so i already prepared some apis
beforehand okay so we have some zip
codes payments employees api so i'm
gonna get
go i'm gonna start uh getting into the
zip codes api
okay right so once i get in i'm gonna
switch into the develop tab
so as you can see this is a pretty
straightforward api we have two
different endpoints uh
exposed through uh through my api okay c
codes and cities
okay so now let's try it out nice
i always wanted some zip codes yeah oh
yeah
within the platform uh you have uh
well from a developer api developer
perspective you will have the trace tool
the trace tool will enable you to enable
you to have a
memory picture of what's going on within
the traffic within the traffic club or
your api
so the only thing that is that i need to
do is to start a trade session
okay once i started i can send over a
transaction
okay i'm gonna hit send
and immediately i'm getting a 401 so as
you can see
i'm i'm i'm enforcing two different two
different policies one of them is a ddos
protection policy
and the second one is a verify api key
policy but wait a minute
if i go back to my uh develop
uh tab i don't see any policy being
enforced in my flows
i see a if i take a look at the preflow
as i see no policy
if i get into the cities uh resource has
seen no policy
i have a policy defined here but however
this little broken link image here
is telling me that it's not attaching to
my flow so what's going on who's
enforcing those apis
well uh me as a developer as an api
developer within my organization i only
have this development view
for my api however someone up in the
chain of command within my organization
is already enforcing security policies
globally
let's take a look at that so now i'm
going to switch roles and now i'm
going to become ruben gonzalez the
security stakeholder right
me as a security stakeholder i will have
access to
a different configure configuration
artifact called sureflows
okay so over here within shareflows i
already have
one that is defined as shareflow
enterprise security so let's take a look
at it
okay within the share flows i also have
a developed app
so you should you should think of share
flows as shareable libraries essentially
you're going to be coming up with
patterns and that
and and these patterns are uh
essentially
policies that are attached together
right within an execution flow so you
in this case i have a single flow and
this is the policies i already have
pre-attached okay so as you can see well
we call it enterprise security because
mostly all these policies are going to
be addressing security uh
scenarios right so in this case this
first policy is making sure that uh
our backends are going to be protected
against ddos attacks and we are allowing
a rate of 100 transactions per second
right within the second policy i'm i'm
enforcing a very simple
um authentication mechanism which is
very verified api key
right however uh the apigee edge
platform is not limited to this simple
security pattern actually
remember uh we offer multiple security
policies so let's take a look at those
uh at that category
okay so if i click over here in add
policy i'm gonna take
and you're gonna be able to see the
three main categories
uh for our out of the box policies so if
we take a look at the security policies
you're gonna be able to see well there
are multiple ones right
and um and within the platform let's say
if you're interested in using a
token-based mechanism to uh to
authenticate each and every api call of
course you can within the platform you
can use jot's
job tokens jwt tokens uh you can use
saml assertions for example uh you can
use encrypted tokens you can use basic
authentication
um if you're looking forward to enforce
uh odd across the world of course you
can do it as well
okay so there are multiple options
within the platform and of course uh
there's a lot of flexibility for you to
choose and enforce the right pattern
depending on your business
okay nice awesome so
again there are multiple ones uh
remember security is null about just
authorization of the on authentication
perhaps you may also want to restrict uh
or unprotect your backend systems
against content-based attacks so
and these two policies uh these two next
policies address exactly that so this
first one
uh protects your backend systems against
sql injection attacks
and the second one is protecting your
backend systems against uh
code injection attacks nice makes sense
so now that i uh me as a security
stakeholder uh defined this shared
function
uh within my organization then there's
an extra way i can make sure that
no one can do anything about it and it's
going to be enforced globally
and for that we're going to be using our
global environment configuration
right and within our environments we're
going to have what we call
flow hooks so there are three main flow
hooks uh
in an in an environment within with an
apigee edge organization right
so essentially flow hooks are execution
points
for the interactions between the api
consumer and the platform
and of course the platform and the
backend systems but these execution
points are exactly at the edges
meaning the developer will not be able
to touch these edges right this is this
is these are policies and
sections that are enforced globally okay
so
i'm going to switch environment here i'm
going to switch from to my development
environment and
as you can see well here it is
my global enterprise security policy is
being enforced at the pre-proxy
the pre-proxy flow hooks is guaranteed
to execute before the transaction
reaches
your api proxy therefore the api
the api developer will uh well will not
be able to
manage or to change this setting nice so
any api deployed to the test environment
is going to go through these enterprise
security policies that you just set in
the pre-proxy
right correct that and i don't have to
do anything as a developer to do that
which is i think
a big difference from big g governments
where you give them
give somebody a document or you say this
is a process and we're going to check
there's nothing here right you deploy
it'll automatically happen
exactly now the developer is going to be
able to focus on
really defining a nice restful contract
for their apis
and now they're going to be able to
expose those apis in a very
nice way and they don't have to worry
and to come up or get to create it with
a security pattern
yeah perfect and i see you also have a
post flow there too so that means like
if you have a logging policy or any
other things that you want to do after
you get the response back
you know we see a lot in the post target
as well right now we know that
our security stakeholder me as ray
gonzalez as a secure stakeholder i'm
able to import these kind of policies
globally
now now that you can now you're going to
be able also to deploy
new apis we don't have without having to
worry about all these security patterns
now let's take a look at uh
at our monitoring dashboard so within
the platform remember
you will have the ability to set up some
rules and for you to be able to validate
and make sure that you're going to be
able to monitor and investigate
specific security scenarios that you're
that me as a stakeholder i'm going to be
interested in
okay so let's take a look our
to our api monitoring dashboard so over
here
you're gonna be able to define your own
um alerts right and these alerts are
based on metadata that is captured by
the platform in real time for each and
every transaction that is going through
okay
so let's take a look over uh to our
alerts that we're already pretty fine
okay so now a common use case for a
security stakeholder is gonna be well
i'm gonna be interested in failed
authentication attempts i'm gonna make
sure that well i'm not being
attacked or my uh or us or a malicious
user is not trying to overwhelm my
um my authorization services right
so in this case i'm gonna create a new
alert in this case this alert is going
to be called
unauthorized access
okay it's going to deploy be deployed in
the test environment
okay and i'm going to set up some
conditions so initially we're going to
set up a basic metric which is going to
be the status code
and as i said me as a security
stakeholder i'm going to be very
interested in
401s because that those this error
relates to on authorized access
right now let's define a threshold in
this case i'm going to define the
threshold as a count
and i'm not i'm only going to allow
10 on authorized attempts every five
minutes
okay i'm going to add an extra dimension
okay in this case i'm going to select
the proxy api proxies as my dimension
right and this condition is going to be
applied to
all available api proxies within an
environment
remember ultimately the api platform
sits on top of your all your existing
backend system doesn't matter
where the where where they are deployed
right so you want the right tool for you
to be able to manage these flexible and
uh
deployments right in this case i'm able
to
to scope down conditions to the api
level however
this condition is a global uh i'm sorry
this filter is a global uh it's a global
one that is going to be applied
throughout all the available apis in the
environment right
and also it's going to be applied
throughout all available regions within
my organization remember you want the
solution that can be
deployed in multiple environments okay
so now now that i set up my conditions
i'm gonna be able to
create notification channels okay within
my alert
uh within my alert uh i can define
multiple modification channels in this
case we support four
uh main channels which is going to be
email
slack then this is a very common tool
that nowadays devops teams to use all
the time
um if you already have paid your duty
you can integrate that very easily or
even if you have a a completely
different setup or custom setup for you
to be able to
be notified of course we can integrate
to that using a web hook
okay so as you can see right this is
that there's a lot of flexibility how
not only ops teams but also securities
but also security stakeholders are going
to be able to monitor specific patterns
and react accordingly in real time nice
so it's a kind of a nice rules engine to
find out issues and
proactively notify it's great exactly
what about from a security standpoint
you mentioned the security dashboards
and
looking at policies and seeing if apis
were adhering to that
yeah remember we discussed multiple
approaches uh we
we mentioned security from uh from a
design standpoint from a non-functional
requirement standpoint
we also talked about automation how you
can perform
uh specific checks even before deploying
your api proxy configuration
but now let's talk about once your apis
are deployed
then how do you make sure that you're
gonna be able to audit
what's going on in the in the api
process that your developers are
deploying into the platform
um and for that we're going to be using
our security
reporting capabilities okay let's take a
look
to our configuration dashboard so over
here this is a single view
of which policies are being enforced or
used with an environment
okay in this case i'm going to switch to
the test environment
actually i already have another
environment prepared for you guys
because this this one will have way more
apis than the ones that we will
use a lot here yeah exactly so in this
case as you can see
um this is a single point of view of
what's going on on each and every
apis that is being deployed okay so in
this case i'm able
to see if these apis are receiving
traffic from a secure
uh from a secured virtual host meaning
all this traffic is being encrypted or
not
okay um also in this case you're gonna
see multiple uh
policies opposite categories that are
being applied
uh or used within an api uh proxy in
this case if i click on the istio aud
proxy and making sure that well a
specific
security policies are being enforced
also
i remember security is not about
author's authentication and
authorization
but also about making sure that well if
someone is deploying some custom code
within your api proxy configuration you
want to make sure that well
this developer is not using any strange
javascript libraries
for instance right so you want to make
sure that security checks were enforced
even
even before deploying and once deployed
that nothing has no
that nothing has changed so this is
pretty cool so
if i look at all this i can just by
looking at it say bo authentication and
this consense api
you know there's no security policies
there against those that is correct and
that's a
big no-no if me as a security
stakeholders i would say well
when what went wrong who greenlighted
the deployment of that proxy what's
going on
yeah let's go and let's go figure that
out nice
so this is really kind of a nice
comprehensive view it's really a sort of
bird's eye view of all the
apis and what security policies they're
using that's awesome reuben thank you
with all that information that we saw so
we saw the enterprise
policies being enforced automatically we
understood a little bit about
the apa platform and we talked about
where we can apply
rules and automation into all of this so
let's take a look back at our use case
so we've got our api team
they're really happy uh but they're
they're about to be unhappy because
they're gonna hit all these speed bumps
right
these big four speed bumps that we have
here so if we used
our automation our governance 2.0
approach and we use this api management
function what would happen
so let's take the first step
architecture review i would say reuben
that we don't need an architecture
review at this point right
if we already stood up apogee we've got
api management platform
i would say the architecture reviews
happen we've stood up the api management
platform
any new api doesn't have to do another
review that is correct so now uh
remember
and the whole point of it is for you to
go to the couple of these patterns and
apply them globally
perfect so that saves us a lot of time
for the api team so they're still happy
at this point
what about on api design so if i go to
api design
and i'm already putting in the policies
or actually i didn't have to if i'm
already deploying apis
and the policies are being automatically
enforced through those flow hooks that
you showed us
security has already signed off i mean
at this point
the only other thing is really around my
payload right so i
i would say at this point anything that
i've deployed is already built in at
runtime so again
i have saved some time there as well on
the api design front
right that is correct even if before
before deploying and even after
deploying you can make sure that nothing
is going on even through our automation
or
through the tool nice okay and then i'm
about to do
you know a pull request uh i have my
tech leads going to take a look at
you know my code you know good news is
if i deploy
in this new governance 2.0 and if we put
in linkedin tools
we've actually done other security call
outs to something like a check marks or
something
or any other kind of uh regular
expressions you know i'd say at this
point for internal standards review
i've already automated it per build
right so as a developer
i know kind of what i'm going to be
tested against i can run it
you know during my build time and i
could see the results so again i would
say reuben
you know i'm going to put an x here we
don't have to
hit that speed bump anyway anymore for
the internal standards review as well
what do you think
exactly again uh throughout either to
the true or automation you can make sure
that well
you're working with the rate right with
the right patterns and you're gonna be
able to see the reports
nice so my rework cycle has already gone
down by a lot so what about the last one
i'm going to hit this deployment i'm
talking to the ops teams
you know certainly i think you know
given given most companies
and organizations we worked with there's
probably still a need for somebody to
manually hit the button
just to make sure things are right but
you know from essentially
providing the information and generating
the report
about what's been done i would say that
you know we can
generate these results automatically and
get them to the ops
folks so that they can do a final
approval so maybe not a full two slashes
but i would say we probably cut that
time
down in about half or even more by auto
generating
for ops and getting that final approval
on the deployment
what would you say to that yeah it might
change depending on the industry there
are some folks out there that might be
uh have
may might be used to have many many more
checks before deploying something
into production perhaps if you're into
financial industry perhaps you're going
to have way more stages even
even the ones even the ones that we
already covered here today
so it changes a lot and also changes
depending on the level of the maturity
level for
uh for your devops teams yeah yeah it
certainly changes
but i think in general you know what we
see here is that you're
reducing a lot of that effort that a lot
of teams have
already had to incur because of the way
governance was set up before
right so with these modern tools you
know we've totally been able to launch a
lot faster
and i think the best part is most of
this is built into the process right so
the design is built in the quality
the security and the testing is built
into the development life cycle
rather at the end you know that's that's
the part that is also saving us a ton of
rework and ton of wasted time
uh that's been happening in the past
let's recap reuben let's take a look
what would be the
let's take a look at the key takeaways
for api so you've got hundreds of apis
maybe
thousands and you've got to deliver them
at speed scale and quality
you know what's the top things that you
need to consider number one
is shift your thinking api governance
2.0
is about a center of enablement not a
center of excellence you are not in
command and control
you're you're there to enable and
empower the api teams within the lines
of business within your enterprise
to go faster and you help them get there
with real quality tools
the second is architect security upfront
with an api management platform
something like apogee
when we build uh apis when we build that
management
platform with the api with apigee we're
working with security
you've got security involved in the
design of the architecture
that ensures a trusted platform set up
from day one
the third in which reuben has showed you
around
centralizing those security policies you
know you no longer have to make it an
obligation for every developer to do
these things
now you can centralize that creates a
separation of concern
let security in let them be part of the
enforcement of these policies
and not only is it about setting the
policy it's about including them at run
time
you actually don't have to give anybody
documents anytime you deploy an api
automatically built into the runtime
that's a real powerful
governance enforcement right there and
it also makes the lives of the
developers easy because they don't have
to worry about it
you know that's a nice check there so uh
what's the fourth one
standardize the inclusion of enterprise
policies so
whenever you started to create these
secure processes and you standardize
them
you're also looking at ways on how to
automatically
produce more policies that might protect
the the company from other things so
it's not just about security
but it's also about you know sql
injections or threats
or quotas or traffic management policies
that might be
important to include edit and oppress
levels so look for ways to standardize
more that and reduce the developer load
and then last of all you know there was
a lot of tools that apogee can work with
automate your keyway and your compliance
so include that that's really sort of
that last mile in terms of development
you know get build quality into your
pipeline
use the cicd automate it and include
standards and compliance checks
in your ci cd pipeline so with all of
that i think
you know we we've kind of captured some
of the key ways for
teams that we've seen uh produce apis at
speed
scale and quality that's really
following the governance 2.0 method
and leveraging the apigee management
platform if you're interested
in all of this i invite you to get
started uh if you are already an apogee
customer
just visit and take a look at our docs
page we'll post this up in our resources
and if you're new to apogee you can get
started right away
with a free trial of apogee edge uh just
follow that link
and see how easy it is i mean you saw
reuben use the tool you see him
some of it's like you know essentially
using drag and drop features
and we have apis from apogee that allow
you to do a lot of that
you know from your ide or other
applications that you're using so it's a
really
easy and quick start so with that let's
uh we're getting close to the end of our
webinar session
i'd like to take a look and see if any
questions that we have out there from
the audience who answer
and let me take a look and yeah we have
a couple so let's get started what are
the
first question what types of roles and
skills sets are needed
to develop this level of automation
i would say that it varies a lot
depending on the maturity level within a
developer team so if you're already
leaning towards agile software
development life cycles and already
looking into automation and building a
pipeline for your
software artifacts then moving into uh
this approach of deploying configuration
artifacts into the plot into the
platform it
is gonna be very easy because you're
gonna be able to reuse what
whatever you already have however if
you're just
starting getting to know us agile
sovereign development life cycles then
you can adopt something very simple
very easily within the platform right
just because we're talking about
configuration it's going to be
be way too way easier to understand and
set up from there
from zero perfect perfect okay
thank you and then let's take a look at
the next question we've got
um this is a good one i think i was
thinking this too as we talked
my company has several different
businesses and they have different types
of security
regulatory and compliance requirements
can i really make one global set of
policies
what do you think reuben oh you can
definitely do however depending on the
size of your organization you might have
to come up with multiple security
patterns remember uh
and it all comes down so what what you
just said right
what kind of requirements you're getting
and how you're going to be enforcing
them so yeah technically you can define
global patterns however you might still
want to have that separation of
duties that's separation of concerns so
that the developer doesn't have to worry
about those patterns and then someone is
going to be able to
uh to enforce those patterns globally it
doesn't it that someone might be related
to a business unit to a project
not essentially global of the whole
organization depending on the size of
the organization of course
and so with shared flows you know you
can create those reusable but you don't
have to enforce it
globally you can make them easy for
teams to add as well and there's a lot
of flexibility
and instantiate different variables
exactly you can either
give the option to the developers to
actually enforce that policy if you want
to and do some checks before deployment
or you can enforce them globally again
there are different ways to do it but
the
the the beauty of the fpgh platform is
that you do have those options you will
you can build your own custom way of of
enforcing these policies and onboarding
new developers so that they can
they understand how they are being
applied okay great
i see another question here um i think
we've kind of covered it but i think
it's a really good question just to
reinforce
again the question is does apogee
provide any tools for ci cd
code quality or test automation
so yeah remember everything that you saw
today in the demo
everything from the clicks i did from
the uh developer view
everything there's an api behind it so
the
apiges platform has been built for the
for it to be extensible right
so our customers use maven plugins for
them to be able to deploy
configuration artifacts they use
javascript tools to deploy and also to
test uh
custom code that they deploy within the
platform so
uh out there you you will have multiple
options and of course we also have one a
very strong community of developers
right all our
all our customers are uh are always
engaging with us and
also setting up some questions in our
apigee community and of course there's a
lot of uh
knowledge out there said that and a lot
of open a lot of uh open
up solutions that even even between
customers they start sharing and reuse
and contributing
perfect that's it it's certainly a broad
community to leverage
within apogee and outside um so number
four
uh in terms of the question how big is
the center of enablement team
um first of all thank you for using that
language and starting to think about
that
center of enablement team we see varies
but we generally see
you know a small group within the
central team
focus on evangelism setting standards
and coaching and supporting others
we're looking at probably a handful of
people in terms of the center enablement
from there we see it varying in terms of
how many
you know api teams you're supporting if
you've got
you know 10 or 100 hundreds of api teams
obviously
your center of enable it's probably
gonna have to scale up but over time
right so i don't think this is about
creating a big team
um it's really created a central team to
set the standards and start to coach and
enable other teams to grow
quickly um and there's a
i think this is the last question we've
gotten so it's a great uh
question to end with uh the question is
do i need a dedicated security person on
the api governance team what do you
think reuben
that's a very interesting question most
likely there's someone within your
organization and you're going to get to
meet him once you try to deploy
something
into production yeah most likely
and again these various as well on the
sizes of our organizations however
uh sometimes if you if your team is too
small organization is too small
then most likely the developer will
share that responsibility
however the best practice is of course
from a security standpoint to have that
separate those separation of duties
right so that then
someone has can focus only in tho and
the right security patterns and the
developers can focus on the real this
business value that you want to expose
yeah yeah and so
if we have that separation of concerns
i'd say when you start out with setting
up your api management platform
you know this is the perfect time to
invite the security person to the table
right let's not meet them at the very
end like reuben said you know i think
let's make friends from the very
beginning and have security at the table
designing and architecting the platform
with us together
and then build those policies and the
approach and quality
uh into the platform and into basically
every api that is
deployed and uh so with that
i think um that's that's that's the end
of our webcast i
hope you guys got a lot out of this uh
this webcast and thank you all for
taking the time
and joining with reuben and i today
thank you all
thank you guys
you